hello guys now i know i just released a
video of regarding the other spider-man
and spider-man no way home but since
then something else has been revealed so
there's been a huge editing mistake so
the scene where mj is seen falling from
the scaffold and holding the railing on
the left side of the screen next to ned
we can see another spider-man holding
this railing now i think this is no
other than andrew garfield spider-man
just because there's been numerous set
league photos seen of andrew garfield
holding this exact same railing now i
think what would be really cool if this
is a scene where tom holland spider-man
tries to save mj but fails and then
andrew garfield swoops in and then saves
her now this would bring it full circle
as unfortunately andrew garfield
spider-man failed to protect gwen stacy
in the exact same circumstances anyway
what do you think of this editing
mistake whose arm do you think this is
is this toby maguire spider-man is this
andrew garfield spider-man who do you
think it is also if you want to watch
another video on editing mistakes from
the spider-man no way home trailer
please check out the previous video that
i made on this topic with out of the way
please like and subscribe to show your
support thanks for watching